είμαστε τώρα στη ρουμανία ερκούμε στην κύπρο τοντα οκτό μεδάνικά που την τράπεζαν ιδρίο μία
κανοβιοίχανί με ολά δανικε σημεωσ δ όι ποτέπου δεν είχαλετά αφ τώρα τα ούείχαν πάντα
επιστάυκανοτόρνα ρίτησο πολέγατομηρούχος δεν ποτε μου πολέγατοήρω ατι ώ ότι είχα τώρα τα λα έκαννα
συνέχα λεφτά μετελογική και τρο ταεκαέτροτα το ζώ λοιπόν και φτάνομε να έχω να ενεργοστάσιο
να σε μια φφάση μποράν αργοτοτούσα και τρακόσαίντα άτομα λοιπόν και ξεκινούν οιιστορίες αι και
ποφέρασπίτι μου ανθυμάστε τότε την όλαύ ου τοπου την ευρώπη και νοείτε επειδή ούνα κούμαρ
ξανεμένατι ναβροιβραντίποτα ότε ούτε ούτ ένα σε εν έχαμε στην τραμέσ λοιπν εστήσα που μια
δίκη στη θεσαλλον ίκη στην οποία κατηγορούμο έχρι και ισόβια κάθυρξη είχαν ι κατηγορίες και
εκεί ξακεινά το βιβλίο μου το βιβλίο μου ξεκινά όταν στέγουμε με στο διγαστήριο αντιμετωπίζοντας
στην κατηγοράτης ιους όδιας κάθηρξη αντδιόχι γιαο τοοδίο έχει γις πιο ωρίς το ιόχι γιτεσε
ένα δωτρία κάπου γιαμέ καικιμε ήταν που άρκεψα και ξυπνούσα καιάρκεψα ανα γνωρίζοδον αυτό μου
ας πο διαδή εύκι μα στα διαλήματα της δίκης έξω βλεπας πούμε έναν πάπου ίμε
στο δρόμεν ένα ζηθιάνο και ζήλευκά δήλευκάτων περιπτερά γιατί τούτοο άνθρωπος είχα κάτιποεν είχα εγώ
την ελευθεραν ουείναιτούτηείναι μια τα δικασία που θεπρασί κανένα θεαή τούτον πουμτύτον που ο κάμαν
και κάτω έβαλα τη λογική μου κάτω επιασα την υπόθεση στα έρκα μου να δώ
γιατί με κατηγορούν αφού δεν ήξερα γιατι επαμ εφορτόςσαν που μια ενεταιρεία ότι ετα δικήμου
και ότι έκαμε θεμπόρια και πράγματα και λοιπόν και κάδικάστικακαι και το πρωτόδηγον δικαστήριο μετημώρισα
με οκτώ χρόνια και φτάμηνές φυλάκις και έχαμε πάρτυκητηνήμέρα που τη χαρακι τ ήταντικατηγόρες που
μου βρήκαν τέσθερες λαθρεμπορικές